the one aspect of the
partnership society that was hung on to
by the dominator
society
was orgy
you know these bdi weasels were willing
to take control but they weren't willing
to say goodbye to nookie
so
of all the
institutions of the pastoral society the
one thing they were interested in
hanging on to as long as possible was
the saturday night uh
grope
so
and for obvious reasons but they didn't
take hallucinogens you see an orgy or
group sex
in the absence of hallucinogens
is just an invitation for the weirdest
most dominator oriented most acquisitive
most driven most ego obsessed people to
take over
for them it's a gratification of ego and
sex is very often used as a
gratification of ego so there was this
effort to retain it finally they saw
that try as they might to pervert it
into just men having a lot of sex with
women
it it was in and of itself boundary
dissolving and
quasi-psychedelic
and so very reluctantly they decided
that has to go to
and then created
the the modern kind of bonding which is
basically that men own women i mean
that's what it boils down to
monogamy
is
not really an issue here
the um
there may have been monogamy in these
societies except that there was
permission for the dissolving of all
boundaries
that's what was important it wasn't that
they didn't have sexual boundaries it's
that in the religious rights those
sexual boundaries were dissolved
monogamy is a model for relating to the
other
through
intense involvement with one person
whether or not you have one or many
sexual partners
seems to me more a stylistic thing
we connect
relationship to sexuality so intensely
that
we can't conceive of separating them yet
in tantra
as classically practiced you know before
it went the
got into the hands of the rhaenyra ale
buddhists
tantra
there was high stress on not having
attachment to the partner
you know so they weren't advocating
romantic love and partnership bonding
they were advocating a kind of
analytical approach to sex
where what you're really concentrating
on is internal states but you do have to
have a living partner to do this and
they are also involved in the sex act
and they are also then experiencing
their own internal
set of states
so i i think that
what i've seen in the amazon that i
really like
and and to a degree at esselm too
it's very
good to take off your clothes
it's part of armoring
about the ego
we do it at epsilon and we pass each
other in the baths and we see what
everybody's got
but we're well behaved
and in a sense that mitigates it
slightly we're well behaved because we
give each other lots of space and
respect in an amazon tribal situation it
is pretty rye bald i mean people say
outrageous things to each other they
feel completely free to comment
on you know your anatomy how you're
carrying on what you're doing with your
sex life
and so there's this kind of jovial
camaraderie where
everybody we live on two levels
the level of where we know what's going
on sexually and then the level where we
pretend we don't know what's going on
sexually
and we are schizophrenically able to
handle this we call it
we call it sexual fantasy
you know i have a fantasy about having
sex with somebody but i would not
particularly walk up to them and begin
describing this
in an amazonian tribe they would
they just say you know and and the
oldest women
are the most
body and obscene and that is almost
their function you know and once you are
beyond
years you're into your older years
beyond where you are actually
a potential mate or conceivably
desirable as the mother of anybody's
child well then what your function is is
to just go around and dig at everybody
and uh and the male ego
is cannot tear loose in this situation
because these hags these old women have
put downs that would shrivel a flagpole
you know
so
so
there's and there's a lot and in i have
been with tribes where there were
group sexual activity behind
hallucinogenic drugs
well everybody gets it back together by
monday morning but if by monday
afternoon
somebody's wife has been seen in the
bushes with somebody else
this is a huge issue the guy is
completely furious
why didn't you wait till saturday night
what's the matter with you you know
you're shaming me
everybody thinks i'm a jerk you couldn't
wait till saturday is that it you're
just a
[ __ ] this kind of thing so you see it's
all in the mind this stuff about
propriety and property and when and
where and how
i don't think that i think that the
mushroom accentuates sexuality but it
really doesn't offer a form for it if i
were
running
society what i really like
is uh
and i've seen this in the amazon i think
that they're at the solstices and at the
equinoxes
we should have boundary dissolution
parties
where
you do you can
sleep with anybody any sex you can have
any configuration anything goes on
only four times a year
and then everybody gets it together and
returns to their mate and goes back to
the field
we get tweaked
you know we think i don't know we we are
obsessed and possessive we all are
possessive we can't just
let it go
you know
but
what i see in these societies where
there are periodically
a group decision to dissolve boundaries
and a group agreement that the
boundaries will be re-established
then everybody gets to act out their
fantasy
with no blame
and usually you know acting out a
fantasy is the very best thing for
depotentiating it and having it release
its hold on you and then you can return
to the life that you really chose
whatever it is
and be
content in it we just we ask so much of
ourselves and mistreat ourselves so
badly in these areas and we
almost in almost all our sexual
negotiations
somebody loses
you know and it shouldn't be like that
it's all in the head there's a way to to
re-wire it so that it's always a win-win
situation and that doesn't mean tilt
toward monogamy or promiscuity or
anything else it just means
being a little more
out front about who we all are and what
we really want
and
and
you know how we define commitment i mean
i grant you that it's easier with a
rainforest tribe of 70 people who have
birthed
each other's children and buried their
dead and shamanized and hunted and taken
drugs together and and so forth and so
on but nevertheless we all have our
affinity groups and
and if we if we put a lot of time into
this
this this could be a part of things this
is very threatening to the dominator
culture because you know no matter what
is said what's really going on inside
the dominator culture is that women are
property
and
in a way the whole psychedelic
celebration
that we've been involved here this
weekend is a celebration of the feminine
the partnership society of pre-history
was a celebration of the feminine now we
tend to think in terms of gender
divisions and to think that if you are
praising the feminine this is a knock on
man
this is very silly
the great division between the masculine
and the feminine
is not the division between men and
women the division between the masculine
and the feminine is the division between
human beings and plants
we are all
solar apollonian masculine
yang
creatures being a creature
is to be that
and then what we're trying to reach back
to
is the vegetable
matrix
what makes half of us
more feminine
than the other half
is not the configuration of the genitals
but the biological
set up for birth
women give birth
birth is
the quintessential boundary dissolving
uh experience
very few women and certainly very few
women in primitive societies can evade
this
women have a lot of children in
primitive societies they give birth over
and over again
birth destroys and dissolves boundaries
and puts you up against
the mystery and this is why women by and
large
are more in touch with what's going on
not because they're better not because
they made a choice
but because
the the way in which they are welded
into the larger processes of the world
necessitates boundary dissolution where
you know a truly uptight male
can probably manage to go from birth to
the grave without ever experiencing
boundary dissolution the fact that women
have a greater predilection for multiple
orgasm
means that they are closer to this
possibility of boundary dissolution that
they have less resistance to repeatedly
seeing it all flow away and generalize
in some kind of oceanic feeling so
in a way what the
the way i interpret this psychedelic
plant thing is we are trying to recover
the guy and mind we are trying to come
into alignment with the life of the
planet which affirms then
what has happened on this world and what
is going to happen
on this world it affirms dao
it affirms the larger processes in which
we
are embedded this is what it means to
hang loose and cool out it means that
you the ego is finally the volume is
ratcheted down enough that you can
notice
what is happening around you that the
world is in a state of perfection
moving toward a state of higher
perfection and that anything which
detracts from that
can usually be traced to a lower
dimensional use of language and that as
we empower ourselves
to higher and higher dimensions of
experience and language and recovery of
mnemonic material as we do that
anxiety leaves us
and we find
the correctness in what is happening to
the world we accept
the
falling away of everything
that we call the past
and we accept then the inevitability of
the adventure
that being in the future then represents
and the psychedelics you know give this
give you an intimation of this all at
once
that you can carry forward with you
until uh
you know
you also return
into the earth and your
organizational intellecki
cuts the deal with the tikes that
they've been wanting to make in all
those trips and then at last you know
you can go off with them
into the hyperspatial ecology of souls
of which we have had simply the dimmest
flickering
intonation
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
you